what we're gonna look at today is to
pick up the story that we've been
involved in for quite a while now of
accidentally discovering that one's
written across compiler the first ever
one I wrote and I almost didn't realize
I was getting into it for those of you
have been following the story so far
I've been trying to motivate T diagrams
as a way of understanding compilers in
general to illustrate the idea of moving
compilers around or coping with hardware
that won't talk to one another we did
before Arduino and Raspberry Pi we say
everybody speaks very quickly to each
other nowadays was it like that then not
a chance
there wasn't a component to universal
component you can put in the middle that
would bridge a to be in a very very
powerful way for the infamous Linotype -
OH - jailbreak problem that we've
covered a lot in videos this was the one
step before laser printers came on the
scene the trouble was that the 202
typesetter wanted everything down its
own non-standard parallel port what I
had to do was to Commission a single
board z80 chip so fairly low-level
character at a time stuff was coming
down here it was being sucked into the
z80 board as serial because it was
simpler but out port as parallel to be
compatible with a parallel input port on
the line a tronic - whoo - typesetter I
would point out that our bridging board
here was hardly high-tech Steve Marchant
who built it for me was a typical
electronics engineer you shouldn't be
messing about with saying everything
could be done in the assembler I'm being
very generous with you I'm giving you a
2k ROM to put your program text in and
if you can generate that out of C and
not overflow fine but also bless him he
did give us an absolute lifeline which
comes off the top of this diagram he did
provide a monitor port from a VD you if
you're in the UK VD t if you're
elsewhere in the world video display
terminal dumb terminal
just showing you the flow of characters
into and out from and that saved our
lives many a time in debugging what was
going wrong the problem is that if
you're gonna put error messages out on
the VDC they have to be stored somewhere
he provided us very generously with 2k
RAM richest beyond the dreams so yes it
the tool camera I'm got very four
because I remember Julian who took those
projects over from way coming and saying
we would get on very well if only we
could do without the error messages once
upon a said we can't
so we phoned up Stevo was not very
sympathetic and said it was all due to
our being computer scientists and not
electronics engineers and need a given
as a thing for very good reasons we're
at the low end of memory was our 2k of
RAM sitting on top of that was the 2k of
ROM in the memory space which was
actually reading the characters
preparing them for parallel listening
for responses all this kind of stuff so
when Julian now I said can you give us a
more RAM know what he did he gave us two
K more around sitting on top of that law
so our RAM holding was split into two
never mind said Julian quite rightly
said we'll keep the lower level of
around for the actual buffering of the
characters we'll keep all the error
messages in the upper bit he said you
know frankly we're only about 40 bytes
short of what we need but we have to
have more anyway we did our plod
interfacing program wrote it in C but
the white Smith's system reduced
everything to assembler so they had
their own Zed 80 assembler so you could
do assembler inserts and these could be
linked into your C generated low-level
code all in one big happily family but
in the end it got united into a single
big assembler level programming around
the assembler you were scarcely aware of
doing it because by this time it was all
packaged up into a shell scripts and you
just sort of ignored the detail we were
happy for it to happen
physically what happened was you
prepared your program you've turned on
the prom
it's a EEPROM an EEPROM is a
programmable read-only memory
electrically driven you made a one-off
effort and you burnt your program in
there and you took it off your target
board you plugged it in you hoped it
works if it didn't work then there was
an electrically erasable option to it
and you could reuse it I don't know I
mean eventually I think would have got
tired but I don't think we ever had to
use more than one but anyway that was
the way it worked so it was a physical
transportation mechanism you walked over
you put it in to the driver board and
you thought this time I've got it right
it's going to work well you're looking
at diagrams like this even at the time I
began to get quite philosophical about
this and think well you know there's so
many questions you could ask here here
am I sitting here producing my
cross-compiled z80 code and it is
cross-compiled because it's a different
binary for the z80 than it is on the
pdp-11
where it's actually being produced
wouldn't it be wonderful if only I could
have far more memory for data and the
program on that board I mean 4k may be
enough an electronics engineer but
really let's get serious it's pathetic
I also thought well we do this and we
come with choose to come in and
interface the one character down a
parallel port level now we knew actually
the line of Tron co2 typesetter was
front ended not by a pdp-11 but by
another 16-bit mini computer it was
called the naked mini it was made by a
firm called computer automation it was a
16-bit machine generally speaking it was
slower than a PDP LEM would have been
but it was adequate enough for the
clunky electromechanical backing and
forwarding a bromide at the 202 had to
indulge in liner type had bought in and
off the peg sorts of solution I think
the reason when it was called the naked
mini
you could get a version with really no
frills and furbelows no case it was a it
was a component you could build into a
bigger system and all that's and
everything you added on to was an extra
probably including the keyboard knowing
that law but you see the more courageous
attitude which Bell Labs did but they
have how should we say more experience
better skills and better lawyers than we
had is to say blow this that's not
really a very good place to intervene
why don't we mount an invasion and
invade the naked mini and take it over
completely and that's what Ken Thompson
did of course in the great jailbreak got
himself on there his favorite
implementation language was the B
language which remember BCPL B is the
first interrupted language still
typeless C came along developed mainly
by Dennis but consulting can to be
v-system implementation language
so first Ken's first reaction are
getting strange machineries right I'll
look up how the assembly works look up
how the code is right now below and
overnight I will pour my B interpreter
and get it working on here and of course
within a few weeks he'd got absolutely
everything in there working of his cross
compiler cross interpreter and
everything and in many ways that was a
way to do it because he could then
decide do i port the whole software
mechanism onto that machine or would i
be better to say i know enough now to
drive it directly from the PDP 1144 and
bypass that largely so a lot of time was
spent with his software decoding what
the heck the 202 was up to in terms of
rendering fonts and it took a long time
to figure out what they were doing with
the characters and so on so it still
prompts the issue do you invade the
enemy territory or do you stand off in
the background and and arms the length
using tolerance just gently feed it the
odd serial line cow
and we had to we just had to take that
less of you
but with my thoughts about wouldn't life
be easier if only I had a bigger zhe
memory could I actually host the
compiler on that or would it be
hopelessly slow yes it probably would
but in theory could I do it although
it's an 8-bit micro and appeared
coincidentally or not in the sinclair
zx80 S&X 81 around about that time there
was a lot of people asking could we
cross compile stuff for the zx80 and
compile it and run it and at Cambridge
at the time there was a gentleman who
will be known to many of you because he
became famous in the UNIX world
Steve born stillborn is perhaps best
known for writing the canonical Bourne
shell that comes as part of UNIX but
before he took the job at Bell Labs he
was a PhD student and a researcher at
Cambridge and he wrote a system called
Algol 68 C was dialect for the Algol 68
language and his big aim since Algol 68
was his baby was I can only imagine
because there's reports of these
experiments going on can i generate code
on here for the z80 and what is the best
way for me to do this
so all these zhe boards we working with
with Cloud Sinclair and his boys you
know it will be lovely to be able to
prepare lots of code for them what's the
best way to do this well I had a great
big IBM 360 machine and what they
discovered was their precious Algol 68
compiler and they went through all the
tricks we've covered in previous
episodes of getting it to compile itself
or getting it to compile a stripped-down
version of itself what they found was
that in the process of preparing a
stripped
down version if I've got this right the
actual compiler itself had to get very
big for a while in order that it could
generate a smaller version that would
fit on the said eighty and when you say
well what's very big a hundred K and you
are limited by the architecture on a Zed
80 to 64 K no solution you had to cross
compile yeah and and they did but I
think also which is perhaps even more
interesting in fact I went to see Steve
at the time and I don't know ISM
actually seen him since this really was
in the very early eighties I remember it
well I think it was back on vacation
from Bell Labs and he said you know the
more you look at this business of
transporting or porting as it now called
a compiler to a new environment the more
you realize what a mess we get ourselves
into we've got this language which gets
compiled down close to binary on this
machine then we want to do it on another
machine like the spectrum and if we're
not careful we start all over again so
we must do the whole chain must get
everything ready and all that but he
said you know the hardest bit in writing
a compiler is not all the syntax
analysis and deciding what to do it's
actually doing it in the code generator
against an environment that can often
see very very hostile indeed wouldn't it
be great if one could have a sort of
assembler level vaguely intermediate
code that everybody could use now he was
one of the early people to realize this
and he said I don't have invented this
thing called Zed code so my compilers
now don't go to a specific binary in one
step they omit Zed code and then for the
new machine you don't have the whole big
compiler to transport what you're saying
is the Zed code is the back end the
syntax analysis whatever is the front
end all you need to do for new
architecture is write as n code
compiled of our interpreter as it said
code he said yes my new colleagues at
Bell Labs wanted to call it Zico and I
keep telling them I'm from the UK
it's my baby it's that Kahoot this
approach at the time became so well
known and so discussed that it even had
its own title the uncalled problem uncle
I think he stood the universal computer
language the forlorn hope was that it
might emerge from all those doing
compilers that there would be one
superbly capable intermediate language
which every single compiling system in
the world could subscribe to and be
happy with its facilities and so on so
the search for the uncle solution
predictably it doesn't work like that
there's always enough difference in
architectures and maybe even today that
it is not easy to have a one size fits
all so I think this is a good place to
draw a line for the moment and so we've
got to investigate how do intermediate
codes work how do they help you por tu
compiler from machine a to machine B we
vaguely see that it can obviously help
because all your having to write to get
a foothold is an intermediate code
interpreter for the new back-end and
that gets you started control C control
C because it councils things love done
right control seek is a 2 to 500 pixels
squared usually training them takes all
the memory